plenty of podcasts available for your
perusal via NBC sports PFT p.m.
available now the week for awards with
MDS Chris Simms unbuttoned coming later
today deep film dive on week fours games
the Peter King podcast available now an
interview with Texans receiver Kenny
Stills and rohtul world available now
fantasy football podcast waiver pickups
for week five I'm glad I saw that
because I forgot to do I always forget
to do my waiver claims which means I
never get dibs on the good players in
fantasy football which means I stink and
nobody cares
shocker here's something you should care
about today's draft week five matchups
the most important of those matchups and
the first matchup is Chris Sims versus
trivia to determine the first pick in
the draft Chris the Pittsburgh Steelers
have now won 17 straight home games on
Monday Night Football their last home
loss on Monday Night Football came in
1991 against which NFC team hmm Wow 1991
which NFC team gosh I mean that's like
the most broad question in the history a
37 years ago there was a game and they
lost on Monday night okay I'll go with
the San Francisco 49ers the other
question you're wrong the other question
was harder much harder and I thought
this one would be easier for you I
didn't come up with her but I thought it
would be easier because it was your dad
was on the team it was 1991 Wow
Giants now he was on the bench maybe
that's why you didn't notice but that
would make it even more likely do you
remember maybe it was the same week you
put the shaving cream in Jeff Hostetler
shoes yes maybe that shaving cream in
his shoes helped him you know play
better that night in Pittsburgh when the
Giants beat the Steelers so yep I now
that you're saying and I do remember it
though I do yes so go ahead that was a
screwed up question I hate no it wasn't
about know it wasn't because it was in
your brain somewhere it just took a
little while for the computer yes to
reboot right and let's stay in
Pittsburgh for the first matchup of the
week I'm talking about this last segment
but this this is an important match up
yeah
Lamar Jackson versus the Pittsburgh
Steelers defense and I've got two
reasons for this first he's never
faced the Pittsburgh Steelers defense as
the starter both games last year
Ravens Steelers happened before Joe
Flacco got bench right so he was in
temporarily in one of the Steelers games
threw a pass ran the ball a couple of
times that's it he's going to get the
full Pittsburgh Steeler defense
experience and the other reason why this
is important 2012 and Robert Griffin the
third is a teammate of Lamar Jackson now
so RG three can help prepare him for
this 2012 was the year that RG three was
taking the league by storm Washington
played in Pittsburgh that season and the
strategy for Mike Conlon's defense was
to beat the crap out of RG three every
chance they could get and it worked
and I think that Lamar Jackson better
get ready he'd better bring a second
chinstrap for Sunday because the
Steelers are going to apply physicality
to him every chance they get same head
coach same concept a mobile athletic
running back quarterback rather who
likes to run the ball and that guy is
going to get hit if he runs the ball at
all and he better be ready for it
because it's coming on Sunday in
Pittsburgh yeah well I mean you're right
it's a great matchup it's gonna be fun
to see the Steelers front seven is the
real deal Holyfield I mean gosh and you
just you go across the board there you
know TJ watt bud Dupree they're really
good on the edge and then case you know
Heyward Casey Heyward and step on to it
in the middle I mean they're they're
beasts they really are along with Devon
Bush a middle linebacker and that's
gonna be an exciting football game
certainly it would not be shocked if the
Steelers found some way to pull that out
okay my first pick I'm gonna go with one
that I'm really interested to see it's
going on down in London and that's
Khalil Mac verse the Raiders offensive
tackles why okay first off the the Bears
being three and one
the Raiders being two and two it's a big
football game nonetheless you always got
to worry about Coolio Mac and and his
ability to ruin a football game and not
just in the pass game but the run game
too he's phenomenal there but more
importantly or what even puts more of a
microscope on this whole thing or
spotlight whatever the
you say is the Jon Gruden Coolio mac
factor right and Jon Gruden I'm sure is
gonna have a few special ways to make
sure Khalil Mack doesn't go crazy this
week and kind of reignite that
conversation of how did you let Khalil
Mack get out of Oakland you guys should
have paid them and of course Khalil Mack
wouldn't like nothing more than to throw
it into the Raiders face and Jon Gruden
so that's one of the best matchups I'll
be looking forward to this weekend yeah
I think that one makes a lot of sense it
was on my list exactly phrased that way
because both tackles are probably gonna
have to deal with him as they bounce him
around and try to find openings in the
formation to get him through to Derek
Carr who actually had a pretty good game
on Sundays he did for the Raiders had
Indianapolis and you know the Raiders
have to be feeling confident coming out
of that game and we'll see if that
confidence translates to some sort of a
plan for dealing with Khalil Mack
alright mine is Thursday night Aaron
Donald versus the Seattle Seahawks
offensive line even though last year the
Seattle Seahawks offensive line was
improving Aaron Donald had three and a
half sacks in two games against them and
we saw Donald get neutralized by the
Buccaneers online to a certain extent
and what happens when that occurs it
doesn't happen often but when it happens
the Rams are more likely to lose so it's
gonna be on the Seahawks own line which
is even better now than it was last year
can they handle Aaron Donald and that
regardless how many sacks the eff up the
play factory I call it Kris will he be
blowing things up and making it harder
for Russell Wilson or will they keep him
in check yeah that'll be a cue the
football game I mean there's no question
Mike and really I'll say this the one
thing the Bucs did last week I thought
to neutralize Aaron Donna let alone just
blocking him well upfront guys like
Alomar put a left tackle did a
phenomenal job and they they use the
back to chip them a little bit but this
might be something we see on Thursday
night's matchup the the Buccaneers
played a lot of two and three tight end
sets Mike Wright to kind of slow down
that pass rush make them think about the
run and they were patient with their
rushing attempts in the football game
that's the best way to slow down Aaron
Donald but that is a key to the game no
doubt about it okay my my next pick here
I'm gonna go to Dallas Green Bay alright
Dallas Green Bay I'm looking at Amari
Cooper verse joy Alexander I always like
to look up for like some cool you know
secondary verse wide receiver matchups
and the Green Bay Packers are a team
that will play a lot of man-to-man and
they will matchup gyre Alexander against
the best wide receiver on the other team
Amari Cooper is phenomenal and if you
play him man-to-man too much he will
torch you that's the one thing I took
away I thought Marshawn Lattimore did a
good job against Amari Cooper last week
on Sunday Night Football but the Saints
played zone mostly for the night it
wasn't a lot of man-to-man so he wasn't
stressed that way I don't think Mike
Pettine will do that a lot he's gonna
let Jay Alexander get into Omar Cooper
space and really that'll go a long way
to see who wins the football game
because Dallas a lot of their past plays
in the drop back pass game are set up
for Amari Cooper to be the first read
and of course other than last week have
been very creative so I all have my eye
on that yeah I figure absolutely right
Jr Alexander blossoming into one of the
better quarterbacks in the NFL and only
his second season in Amari Cooper look
he's been great ever since the trade
happened last year mid to late October
that brought him to Dallas and that
passing games improved even though they
got shut down to a certain extent on
Sunday night I like that matchup all
right next one for me I was gonna be
even snarky err with it and sake oh here
we go but I'm just gonna call it Kirk
Cousins versus himself because now this
is teed up Chris what's going on inside
the brain box of Kirk Cousins because
how is he gonna try too hard yeah get
the ball to Adam feeling so he doesn't
have to publicly apologize to him again
right is he gonna you know how is he
gonna process his reads how is all this
extra focus on the Vikings passing game
going to potentially mess him up at
MetLife Stadium against the Giants team
that they should beat and if they falter
you have to wonder how much of it is
self-destruction by cousins who may be
thinking too much about the passing game
too much about hitting open receivers
too much about getting the ball to Adam
Thielen and and I'm telling you now that
the green light is there to criticize
it's just a matter of time before Stefon
Diggs pops yeah what special
if he doesn't get the ball cuz he's
hardly gotten the ball this year yeah
well yeah thanks Adam feelin thanks for
doing that to your quarterback and your
offense I mean again I you know it's
amazing that he hasn't taken more
criticism for this you know it's it was
a bullcrap move sorry God got nothing
more to say about that and it taught
Shermer playing his old team that should
be interesting to okay my last pick I'm
gonna go with the Indianapolis Colts
offensive line verse the Chiefs
defensive line because the the Colts
underwhelming last week did not run the
ball well on the Oakland Raiders and if
you go back to the divisional playoff
game last year you know I don't think
Kansas City or Indianapolis as defense
matches up real well with Kansas City's
offense and I worry about the secondary
of the Indianapolis called verse that
Chiefs passing game and everything like
that and I think a big wreath or a big
way that the culture will win the
football game is they're gonna have to
run the ball and control the clock you
know jacobi percent is not Andrew Luck
yet T Y Hilton been banged up the
running game will be paramount for the
Indianapolis Colts if they want to keep
the game close and maybe have a chance
to win the game and that's a huge Sunday
Night Football game even with Andrew
Luck retired and it's barely been a
month since he's retired but you Cober
said has done well yeah Chiefs are still
the chiefs and a lot of good matchup so
let's recap real quick before we take
our break my picks for the best matchups
for week five Lamar Jackson versus the
Steelers defense Aaron Donald versus the
Seattle offensive line Kirk Cousins
versus himself Sims has pilio Mac versus
the Raiders offensive tackles J or
Alexander versus Amari Cooper and the
Colts Olin versus the Chiefs d-line
quick break when we return todd gurley
getting frustrated and it's starting to
show itself in his press conferences
we'll play you some of what he said
yesterday some of what didn't make it to
the transcript that the rams circulated
more PFC live right after I won the
draft
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports